thank you very much prime minister and
what you've announced today
suggests that the pandemic is beginning
to become under control and we may be
past
the worst of the crisis do you where do
you think it would be reasonable and not
irresponsible then for scotland to hold
a second independence referendum
and for professor whitty um your side
showed that the
number of cases of the indian variant
have doubled in the last week
are you at all concerned this could
destabilize the eat lockdown easing
plans and could lead to a further
lockdown in the autumn
well sev on your first point i had good
conversations with all the
uh heads of the devolved administrations
and
uh i can tell you everybody was resolved
that the number one priority for
uh the whole of the uk was to build back
better
uh come out of the craniovirus pandemic
and build that better uh together
um on the indian variant in fact there
are currently three indian variants but
the one that we're worried about at the
moment in the uk
is the 617.2 um
it is it has gone up very sharply and i
think that's a reason for us uh to
be very careful about it and there's a
lot of work being done by public health
england
uh to try and delineate where it is and
to work out ways we by testing and
isolation we can get that on top of get
on top of the curve of that
india has also gone into the red list
which means that
new people coming in would have been
significantly uh reduced
but i think what you you know in answer
to both your question and to the
previous one
what we know is with all the variants
that things can come out of a blue sky
uh you're not expecting it and then
something happened that happened
obviously with the b117 and that has
happened to india
uh with this uh variant as well so i
think we we would
be very important to say it is
impossible i think at this point in time
i think our view is that this is a
highly transmissible variant
at least as transmissible as the b117
variant
it is possible it is more transmissible
but we'll have to see
at this point in time at this point in
time
our view is it is less likely to be uh
able to escape vaccination than some of
the other variants because left one
but the data are not properly in there
so i think it is you know we need to be
cautious until we've seen clear data
that give us an answer one way or the
other that the reason i've given that as
a relatively technical answer
is of course we don't know whether this
is going to cause significant problems
in the autumn
the way to deal with that is identify
the cases which have been happening
isolate where we can which is also
happening get through the rest of the
vaccination program
and ensure that we have the capacity to
pick these up uh
and also to re-vaccinate uh as necessary
when the autumn comes
the final point on this is the way to
prevent
the number of variants that circulate is
obviously get on top of this as a global
problem
and that's something which all of us are
absolutely determined to support